all right and we are both live
flashpoint returns he boxes I missed you
man what's going on oh man it's been a
good couple of weeks I know I'm catching
up with you as you were out in the e3
world living the dream so I'm actually
rather jealous of that one
let's glad we got you owe yourself one
III as a gamer
no it's an eventual it's gotta happen
but didn't happen this time seems like
you had a pretty good one though
definitely being is your little Xbox
Xbox love you guys had a pretty good
conference they're definitely uh I don't
get all that slander from about it
slander a lot of fun being out there
Love III every year as a game when you
owe yourself one III it is um it's just
a tremendous it's like the Super Bowl of
gaming you know saying you mean everyone
and everyone you know different places
and um it's just somewhat fun but it's a
lot of work as a content creator you
know it's not it's not just you know fun
and games and I'm playing games and
that's it it's definitely not work but
uh I had a lot of fun shout out to the
team the Lords tick was in the building
and um yeah man we really really kind of
try to get as much balanced coverage as
possible and of course some Destiny's
forsaken seriously I heard so I mean we
can just kind of jump straight into that
because that has been out there for a
little bit but you got your hands on
gambit didn't you oh yes to chat man I
was yeah I got to play with those guys
and it was a lot of fun my shout out to
uh Sean Finegan who I actually got a
chance to play with actually I was on
the line when it was actually media day
and the first day they allow us to they
got a kind of new set of four you know
it's open to the public now so now how
they balance it is they allow press to
actually have their own day for them
actually no I think all day but maybe
like three to four hours on the first
day to themselves
so on I said you know what man as much
as it's so much let me get destiny now
cuz based on prior III experience the
activision wolves are always insane for
destiny like when it's open to the
public
it's insane yeah so um I said I let me
knock that out try to get a feel again
but so while I'm getting them like look
who's online with me fighting chat boy
so shout out shout out to like I said
destiny Sean we topped it up now as we
got closer and it was still alive for
press I mean but just wasn't as crazy as
I know it could be so long yeah we got
closer and then as it got closer
destined he starts to walk off them I
don't like doing what you've done you're
right about we bout to play gambit like
what's going on he's like dude I just
got the text or I guess it was from CD
Projekt RED for cyberpunk no yes I said
you know I I can't get check out that
crazy thing that happened that obviously
from what I've heard was like game of
the show I mean I spoke to so many
people and just the experience isms that
it is it looks like something completely
next-gen that's how amazing cyberpunk
you know somebody says Oh 27:17 so he
jumped off and then he ended up being
mean
Sean Finegan Chomp Chomp so he get it
pop and dawn we broke us up in teams of
four they asked me if I would like to
have my footage on a main screen so I
said yeah no problem so we started it
off um you know pretty much basic fear
you kind of start off or both teams look
at each other you do your dances you
taunt you're on that little you know
drifter ship the guy I guess flipped a
coin random map whatever you start off
so it looks like it was cabal they put
us in this different map area so the
beginning was just trying to get a feel
of the system shooting enemies see the
motes come out then you start banking
them but what I realized was kind of
sometimes better strategy is like to
kinda the game kind of tells you like
hey you got a small amount you can bank
and then yes you if you don't bank you
keep killing and you get more motes you
got you know a bigger amount and that
sends the blocker over there to their
side which is another enemy so we you
know as I start like maybe about a
couple of minutes then I started getting
hang of it and like me and we're in
Finnegan which is wreck into
so it was it was like it was real you
know there so I'm thinking doing well
you know whatever I got it I only got a
chance to go over as the invader one
time you know cuz I was just focusing on
and honestly I had to be complete on
it's like I had a pic war like before I
you got to my station I say hey which
one's the warlock cuz that's how I know
how Activision but you know how to do it
each station represents a class I see
which one is the water and it just
happened to be next to I guess the Titan
where uh show us so we would sit next to
each other so um once we got that it was
to do subclass and I'm looking I'm like
yeah mighty I want to know how to super
is so but first route was just be kind
of best of the route and I had like a
shotgun in primary um and I was you know
social I was something feeling and I was
like look man what would be cool he's
like do you think they were gonna allow
from based on the static UI we saw you
know there was no moving from kinetic to
energy like what was there was static so
I didn't get that sense of moving around
like stuff around I get the sense that
they're gonna be all weapon types in
different slots news I'm saying as far
as the primary kinetic that's not
exciting so I just mess around with that
so I think I went home I went shotgun
kinetic okay I will get this new exotic
bow in energy which is hearing about
that oh it's so good yes let me try it
it's almost like a better linear fusion
rifle really but you could charge it up
to hit hard and the exotic one had this
AoE effect that really destroys mobs and
and yellow bars like if you really aim
how I get you you know you get crits you
um it's really good so well I was
messing around with that and I believe
just for shits and giggles I took a
grenade launcher instead of a rocket
launch and heavy because I wanted to see
if grenade launchers would be any better
yeah like I don't think there's they're
gonna see too much love for a little
while yeah so the red widow
they need a buff badly so the match went
on so we doing pretty well and I'm
looking like damn we got smacked
we started off well then we got smacked
in the primeval came and it was just all
hell broke loose so I'm like alright so
we kind of talked about the Speck
strategy we are we gonna do he went over
we kind of started the formula so now
I'm like okay that's on like literally
we had 40 plus smokes a piece o so in my
mind like we jumped off to such a big
spot like oh this is a wrap we got him
and that's the match is going on like
what's going on like these two no
disrespect to the two other teammates
but man they were just like they were
they were the words like they was not I
guess they didn't understand a cop to be
honest no I don't think they really
played destiny to PvP before well you
had no moats zero no kills I don't quite
understand how that's even possible but
alright literally at the F the
post-college report we looking at I just
looked at I looked at finish I was like
dude we were like we just rolled out
because we were getting into it we get
competitive he was going on his evading
was top-notch and then I was doing that
on the new warlock super when that
radius affecting which one void go had
dog I don't Lee
Oh what is that one all right it looks
like this no what you're talking about
yeah it's the big like kind of circular
but yes
bigger yeah it starts off with like
almost like an attack thing circle thing
like damage to the enemy but then it
ends up becoming like this oversized
peeling rift nice so it's really cool so
I was like I so I was using that over
the dissection where we were trying to
put in most so people wouldn't get
bothered and just deposit but yeah at
the end of the day we're just like you
know we us to was just very dominant we
had two of the worst teammates we got
smoked at the end and I'm just like ah
so you really need a good team of three
to four but the mold is so much fun like
everyone's gonna like it because the PvE
guys you you can you could just stay
doing defense or just go on out your way
to kill enemies and
in your zone the PvP guys are gonna love
it cuz they're gonna want to be the
invader they're gonna want to go in
there cause have and it's cool cuz you
got this whole red hue and the game
tells you the game will give you
indicate like hey an invader has you
know come in or whatever what about the
game constantly communicates with you to
help you understand you know stuff and
they start you can start to get like
really complex strategy so I loved it
man I really thought it's gonna satisfy
on both bases you know this is something
this is something to watch out for
I really enjoyed gambit very cool man I
mean I've only got to get to see it from
a distance but seriously it sounds as
you said it's a nice way to scratch both
itches because you got the PvE the
killing you can have your strategies it
can be like you know your nightfall
strike scoring you gotta have I mean to
be out of elite level you're gonna have
to have some strategy in there hey do we
bang come up right now hey are you gonna
hold on here's okay they got one up okay
send one right over there let's do that
and like you're gonna kind of be ready
to counter what they're gonna do but
then as you said you got the PvP side
you got to go over there you're not
gonna like you know show up as like on
the radar anything but I mean you get a
properly placed rocket or you like you
can get a couple Snipes from a distance
and then you can just mess them up yeah
man
absolutely so many strategies and marks
sniping everything you just said and I
know it's gonna do well it's gonna be do
and now you know obviously we talked
about last time we did a flashpoint you
know people concerned whether it be
matchmaking so now that the level of
entry is good and from my understanding
you know there's gonna be some really
cool rewards tied to it so um yeah
thumbs up thumbs up for me I had a ton
of fun even though we lost it I had it
set of fun but um yeah this thing is
really gonna be cool nice this is very
cool I mean that's that's one of the
biggest things for Forsaken is a
completely new thing they said it's a
you know it's a nice balance of PvE and
PvP now I mean they said it was like hey
it's like a game-mode that's never been
in a shooter before and I'm kind of go
on halo wars own kind of did the PvE and
PvP thing so I mean there's that but I
mean the fact that it's like you have
your own kind of little world you can go
to their realm and do the PvP so it's
got its twist to it just like you're
putting both sides of this game that
have always been a part finally together
and I'm like
I'm really pumped for it honestly it's
gonna do well it's definitely gonna do
well yeah I mean it's one of the things
I think a resounding ly
everybody likes yes that about most
things but I haven't heard anybody say
literally anything bad about this mode
that's a good point
that's girls like it's one of the few
hundred percent positive moments for
destiny I'm like me it needed one of
those it absolutely absolutely doing a
shout out to my boys waffles he always
talked about a mode similar like this
when we first started doing on ILP when
it was destiny only he's like it would
be cool if they had like a mix you know
I'm saying a PvE and this is really
gonna cuz this some guys is just like
hardcore PvP you know really cuz when
you get it over there and they it's fun
it is fun but you got a limit you have a
time you can't stay in there forever
it's like literally I forgot about the
twenty second thirties whatever it is
you know so you gotta get hit the ground
running and find the stalks whatever now
they are it does show up on the radar
you know I believe today when you inve I
remember seeing like on the radar stuff
and I'm saying like where people are and
placement and stuff like that so you
gotta act quick but then it literally
feels like a crucible match and it feels
good get that rock kind of crap actually
got a couple of grenade launcher kills
but it was kind of fun oh man pulling
out the grenade launcher yeah but I saw
a couple of people using I guess it was
just like you had a couple out loadouts
to pick from so you may as well mix it
up a little bit absolutely yeah yeah I
mean that's probably the biggest
takeaway from e3 for destiny was gambits
new mode they didn't have too much on
the story I heard some people got to
play the store admission
yeah yeah yes I suppose those guys that
still guys they got a chance to play the
story and um also um I didn't get a
chance to run I want to shout out
unknown player and by if I did I kept
missing them while we were in different
areas that we had the same area at
different times yeah um you know we seen
his video and everything he broke down
off so he got a chance to uh to play so
basically you know the vibe is you know
what that with our Bungie tends to do is
give you pieces of the campaign and
sometimes it's not even in the same
exact sequence that the final game will
come out in it's just it's kinda like a
vertical slice I guess they have
ideas on a cutting floor but there are
certain core things like cage staff
obviously you know safely a trailer now
yeah yeah so so yeah and the vibe I'm
getting
is it is extremely well done yeah and or
at least that first piece even by if
like I mean come on he's a rip doma part
on the story before I mean in a
reasonable way he's not like crazy about
it but it's just I mean destiny is to
story has its lacking parts I mean it
just was it's kind of incomplete on
coherent doesn't have weight to it and
they cranked it up now here's the
question before you get too far beyond
this one shota
would you rather than never even showed
caves death that's a tough one I thought
about that at first I think my raw
reaction was I didn't liked it at first
right I remember well the fact that he
dies the fact that you know it before
you play it
no the when I watched the trailer first
of all the caveat is I was not I didn't
get a chance to get invited to the
actual PlayStation event yeah what I had
was like a PlayStation experience right
and that was like in this movie theater
where they show you the conference okay
great so I get there and for whatever
reason we got there I was late or
whatever but um yeah man like we they
had us like really up in the front so
I'm looking up and I didn't have the
greatest vantage point of everything
that was going on so I had to rewatch it
and when I rewatched it come on when I
spoke to you we were going back over
text I was kind of pissy remember I was
like so I said you know what let me go
home watch it again and then when I
watched again it had the effect that I
think everybody else had that might be
so I was cool with it because um as far
as you to your original question which
is about spoiling um sad the game
influences lesson fees cake where do I
turn my flash points it's gonna have a
new meaning that kumkum forsaken yeah
man it was one of those things where I
said no I thought it was done well I
think they needed that I think they
needed to show it because testing like
you said always gets criticized for no
story right it gets
and to me this is the best emotional
moment they can do and he signifies a
lot of things in my opinion like you
know a lot of people didn't like destiny
twos whole turn to jokey jokey not
blaming everything on Kade I'm saying
but it's like you know they had that
that comedic turn where things weren't
as dark and we're in a series so that's
the number one most beloved character
you know um yeah I feel you getting four
- it would have been dope if they two
held on to it and I wouldn't I'm not
opposed to the way they did I think it's
making you making the base wanna play
because it's like you're wise Aldrin
doing this right what's going on and
this is our boy and then while skating
the situation at the beginning really
the Queen so it adds a lot of questions
and I think for marketing wise you know
I'm cool with it as long as from my
understanding he's dead but as long as
there's no BS and no magical hiccup
because he's just gonna defeat that
whole weight of the debt if they do that
in my opinion but what what did you feel
did you feel it was a mistake for them
to um to kind of show it right how did
you feel overall now okay so let me
explain my little drop of how it
happened I'm sitting there like watching
the Sony conference just in the
background granted everybody's like this
is a weird Sony conference and we'll
dabble in that first I can hear
basically just the idea like Sony had
their main pillars my opinion they were
coming out with and they honestly
focused out what's coming in the next
you know here so and they had the
gameplay they had the live music going
for more of experience and honestly for
them I think it's like they know we have
four good games we want to play him I'm
still not sure about death stranding by
the way yeah I'm real confused now it's
like granted the concept of when it's
like when he liked the him walking
around like the world so gorgeous and
that came like just him walking around
seeing the mountains and stuff like the
world's a cool I was like I just has to
be something doing to do in those but
when he actually walked out of like the
warehouse and like the little flashy
thing like showed where all the guys
when you look up in the sky like okay
that's kind of serious like there could
be something there but i don't don't--i
to fall empty it but for me i'm watching
that stuff with my brother
and I have it on my computer we're going
through and I'm like live-streaming it
through Sony's twitch not like III is
twitch like directly through Sony's
twitch so I'm watching we're playing PvP
and he's like hey and I was like what
and then my stream cuts out and I was
like wow so like I didn't catch the
first live moment so I'm like dude what
the hell does literally could not get
back in and I saw the final point where
they're walking away and I'm like wait
what just happened I was really really
really computing so your first reaction
of mine were obviously not optimal but
good went back later and watched I'm
sitting there going like I had to watch
it again
I look I just hit repeat I was like what
just happened cuz yeah so then you
watching this like okay first ghost is
shot and I was like okay that's a little
more serious than you see him holding
ace of spades you see who it is the
reveal
you got the scores out there called my
right yeah it's gone yeah yeah I like
there like you know little pauldron mall
things like like the fireballs whatever
the thing they've got those things
swinging behind them as they slowly
creep forward and then just the shot and
you're like you looked at him so I've
watched it like three times I'm like the
lights in his face finally dim I'm like
you did not just so I was like in the
moment I was like holy crap like I'm
hyped I want to know I want to go kill
Holder and everybody wants like revenge
straight up real fast but when you get
to think about it later how much oh well
I was like there's two decisions I don't
know why they did its marketing for sure
Bungie building hype train they did it
they got people talking they had a you
know a little funeral situation outside
of III I saw four oh my god yo dude I
saw that picture and I was like dude I
don't think that was Bungie like I think
that was the fans like I'm dead serious
like dude this thing was out you know
how I know it has nothing to do with
them because dude it was outside on the
sidewalk almost a block away from the
Convention Center
it wasn't like directly out front the
converse and I think it was like an out
of front door or something oh dude this
is like you're walking to your case you
know how you know what a Cowboys play
look how much they anyone ever right
yeah and literally like a full block
away for
you know the interest someone just
happens to do this on street like these
this was a fan base thing you know I was
like it could be fan or as Vicarious
Visions hid something at a forest true
that on it but either way it's still
awesome so yeah it's like when I think
about it's like it's really cool and it
builds the hype awesome but honestly
like after playing a game like Detroit
after playing a game like God of War
those moments in the game as opposed to
the now the way they've described it
heads-up spoiler alert I'll give you
about five seconds from what I've heard
from byfa bout the story this is heavy
spoilers yeah there's a build-up to it
but from what I kept hearing is like you
have those anticipation moments it's
like is this the moment for Kade right
no keep going for a little like so
there's a little bit of build to it but
the fact that you know it's coming I've
like in the moment might take a little
away from it perfectly what you saying I
get what you're saying cuz like we're
gonna play it now for saying come now
we're gonna play we're just gonna die
all right so he's gonna happen now it's
gonna happen now because we know it and
I feel you guys on the shock that it
would have knocked it out the park but
let's be real to your right from us from
a story story it makes it take they took
away that emotional weight of because
you you know you now know but I feel
destiny had to do I'm not mad that they
had to do it I'm not mad they did it
because one they needed something
marketing-wise to get this anticipation
for this DLC I don't have it for marking
like you got a they've been a down in
the dumps they've got this is the
researchers and I'ma be real true like
because of that I've seen non destiny
people that I got destiny but people
who've quit on destiny like y'all I'm in
you know saying we gotta see the
emotional thing that it has so for I
guess what I want to consider the
casuals you know Sam but I think it
served its purpose you know it may not
have blessed us actively with that
surprise factor that we want it but um
people are people are into it man people
I've seen a turnaround that I'm like yo
I
we first thought a flashpoint we
couldn't get anybody to talk about
destiny anymore
me you were like flying this flag high
just trying to keep it alive with whole
a destiny podcast game and not the best
moment to choose it but people were like
why are you even doing a breakdown deep
dive and that's the you know saying who
plays that game like that it's over
right yeah and I'm seeing those people
hit me up in the DMI a-class spots still
open I mean overall it's like I'm hyped
to play it and we'll get to an article
that breaks down a little bit more a
couple cool things I like about it all
in all like Soompi I had somebody
comment on one of my videos basically
just saying hey it's like you know
somebody's got a gun to your head you
play and forsaken I'm like hell yes
I absolutely will because one to me $40
for an expansion with everything that's
coming is absolutely worth it for me
I've played paid more money for less
games and I know how much time I'm gonna
get out of destined to now is it for
everybody no are there a lot of things
coming that might make it for a lot more
people I think it's got a pretty good
shot so but now it's like the story side
is like man that was a gut punch and
everybody's there was something I saw
Toit's did a quick little graphic and
it's like just a headstone for Kay and
somebody's like Oh too soon and it's
like yeah you weren't you're nobody's
gonna be ready for that one
because yeah he's been the backbone I
mean let's be honest you know compared
to the other two Vanguard's you know
it's not even close you say it's not
close so I'm not to be honest now I'm in
that point I'm in the acceptance phase
now for like pains it's cold
acceptance bargaining all that's my dog
that's cool man shot today to the real
Saladin's wolves the rely on but I think
I'm replacement I'm just gonna be the
vanguard ya know that's seriously a good
question cuz you got
zero for mm-hmm honestly I'd like to see
Anna though hmm
and did you see that artwork that ones
you put out about a said that looks very
similar to said Queen ah hold on
we're at Twitter um somebody someone put
it out on Twitter but it's definitely
floating around they floating around
Twitter but I know I'm vice video he's
got it asked across shout out to him
he's got um you they send out some
promotional and I don't play there's not
some promotional image imagery of um of
this character who has this unique
double-barrel about yeah and it's kind
of like it's hooded it you could get
looks like it could be like an older and
it could be in a woke and it could be
any of those but yeah if you look deep
enough it might be the queen or yeah
quite interesting on that one yeah so I
mean there's a lot of options but you
know I'm kind of curious and this is a
point like I mean I've heard a couple
people say it by probably as well as
like this is a turning point because
destiny needs to hit it right so
positive things we hear and so far well
hopefully like I said they got they got
the interest they got the buzz you know
I'm saying so let's just see if they
followed the rule but I think my boy
I've got confidence my boy uh shout-out
to myelin games man he's over there he's
got the job at Bungie with narrative
I feel lords in good hands I mean they
couldn't get by you know that's that's
that that's the guy that's him but I
like Milan a lot man I don't think he
gets enough credit you know saying he's
in my opinion like the number two that
you're gonna say and he's good he's good
I really liked his questions when he
went to community summit so um yeah man
I think laws once they hired him like
how they hired Holtzman you know [ __ ]
about but on O'Shea O'Shea don't say
it's yeah but uh at the end of the day
you know saying like I feel it's in and
no sight the house that's my guy
violence my guy to so that's like but
it's us it's something the game needs
because I mean do you want to know like
what memorable games from Letterman
gonna be for me for PlayStation 4 is it
gonna be like the goofing around and
destiny I mean I spend a buttload of
time in here but my standard says of
late for like this year God of War
ruined a lot of other games for me this
year because of how epic it was in the
story it told and the way the characters
felt yes to your characters and the way
the story progresses out and the
emotions you feel from a game are the
things that make those moments stick oh
and if we don't have any emotion
attached to destiny two of which I don't
think anybody could you know it right
currently has the emotional depth of a
teaspoon like so if they can actually
give weight to some of this stuff it's a
big step in the right direction and I
hope they keep it going nice yeah so I
mean yeah wrap it up III I mean there's
some good stuff coming I can't wait for
spider-man honestly it's gonna be like
the same damn week is destiny too so I
mean real struggles but yeah but least
at least a single play it like I said
isn't a single play destiny can still
survive that you don't say you know you
put desti down for a bit you play your
single play you blaze it out you know
yep you know so looking forward to some
stuff but yeah
September's looking good yeah again this
week so this week at Bungie finally back
at it know last week he you were coming
back from e3 I was travelling happy
Father's Day to all the father's out
there so hopefully you guys enjoyed but
we got a little update from Bungie so
still no news on the summer of solstice
event that's kind of what I was hoping
for but yep there so I mean when it
comes to that one we can take a quick
look at the calendar we got July 17th
were not that many resets away from
mm-hmm
what's coming so you're gonna have next
week but you got the 28th and the 5th
and the 12th like they only got a few
options in here so if not probably next
week maybe possibly yeah so I mean
coming up we got that's the 17th 6v6
quick play Rumble bounties is probably
my biggest question my
on this one so we'll get to the exotic
armor changes but as the one thing we
don't know we know the least about
bounties I'm still quite curious on yeah
very curiously intrigued but I know most
you guys have seen this before you know
what year two is coming and there's
still more to come - so lots of crap
going on which is good for this week at
Bungie we got some stuff rocking here so
as they said they're excited for e3 if
you didn't get to play forsaken but if
you're going to Guardian con me I'm not
going this year just goes a little too
much going on right now and honestly it
feels like it's still gonna have
forsaken but it definitely feels like
it's gonna be a fortnight event as well
oh yeah you know like ninjas gonna be
the last one Guardian gone I'm like no
difference back I'm just you know I mean
I'm cool with diversifying stuff they're
just for me I'm all about that destiny
life now I mean that's well I mean for a
marketing point for them to try and hype
up the event even more to try and sell
more tickets to build it to build the
Thunder like honestly if all that stuff
just gets better fundraising fine with
me honestly go for it
it just for me it wasn't feeling right
this year so so maybe another year we'll
meet up down there and go grab a drink
again do it but four seconds gonna be
there as well so if you didn't get a
chance at e3 you're gonna be in Florida
go play some four-second should be cool
iron banner is going on right now
if anybody's really too hyped about iron
banner and can't quite tell I know you
want that warlocks at me it's that this
iron band is all me man let me tell you
so all my warlock stuff I need my I have
another world I need that ornament so I
gotta ground for that cuz it makes that
helmet look so much better and then um I
gotta get on that graviton like that
that is graviton is already disgustingly
good right now right oh it's insane so
it's like now you giving me hidden him
better target acquisition this thing's
already a laser beam so like oh man I
have to have it like that is my go to my
loadout right now dude I'm racking I got
this new arm sorta this new submachine
gun
let me give you a little hint right now
you'll always give you those little
crucible loadouts you know all right
real quick right now shout out this is
my knowing shop make sure you shout me
out and you start getting your k/d up
yeah you gotta get this is it's a it's a
warm on truck it's all it's called new
city it's one of them devaron kangana's
yeah it's a sub it's a unique um class
I'm he was like a 720 you not I'm saying
it's a unit rpm for the submachine class
in the kinetics lab so you throw that
into kinetic you got your own all shout
the Forte he know what time it is yo if
you're a graviton because I'm there's a
lot of got my guys are vigilant swing
guys and it's like its dominant it's
just I just don't feel right on me
graviton is more myself I didn't have
new city I'm gonna have to move that
over until row
Dorian crucible don't know I got new
city I'm doing that and then I opted you
know I still got my I'm a vote guy so I
still got my wizard rebuked cuz I love
the fact I got so much ammo for it
so I'm flowing with that every once in a
while I may throw in um you know like
sins in the past if I'm just wanna clear
stuff out but because rocket launches
only give you one yeah you know say so
I'm running right now I'm running with
with what you call it with a new city
graviton and um wasn't rebuked that's my
full right and it's just basically it's
Beasley back at the foot graviton feels
like a scout like it's kind of unfair
that Scout can't even compete with it
they think they're gonna have to do
something with the high impact sky I'm
struggling
yeah like scout stick with graviton as
the metter you're not beating graviton
in no range to range tree fight at all
and if they crossed it up forget it you
gonna get that extra damage with the
explosions so that's the new Lord out
check out new city loving that as my
kinetic a little bit even overall Manteo
man that's my floor right now very cool
but yeah I mean for iron banner it's
like I honestly was
didn't know if they were gonna do
anything about the emote they had a
little package out there for a fighting
lion ornament for like an hour and then
there was a glitch so they just took it
out which is fine but I was like I'm
just glad they didn't bring the emote
back for round two otherwise they just
would a little lit it up all over again
so at least they listened left it out
now if you wanted to have a token of
appreciation I wanted to see that thing
come in at level 50 yes just be like hey
if you want to grind it out and get
there cool it's like hey it's just like
anything if you want it quick and early
and you wanted to buy it fine but now if
you want to earn it if you gave us the
option or just made sure if iron banners
up it's in both places if you just did
something like that it would think it
would have gone a little step in the
right direction so yeah iron banner is
going on grind it out have some fun if
you're looking for a good day to play
your heroic strikes
I do believe Sunday it's gonna be your
day again why so what's going on no it's
just your heavy weight for your hurl all
fire and this oh this week nom DFA is is
is this is the week the grind it man
nope it is back it is active so they
switch that one a couple hours later -
so yep that is kind of for sure so MN
it's good stuff DFA is definitely good
one to get may not be the ultimate
button the top loader hand cannons
better Devils midnight coup DFA they're
all right there so if you want an option
mix it up a little bit it's a good one
in the nightfall and have a little fun
and if you get some groups out together
shout out to pyro he's got a little
guide honestly if you guys like have you
know melting point have like boob can
and have all the right in peril yeah
watch happy note that boss no quick I
saw I was couple people go to destiny
Ellis you try and find some and just
melt him I know I even was 2-minute with
guy hadn't played with in a while and we
even - man it took a little while but
he's not a bad boss to manage it's
mostly just the ads and stuff so you can
go through prestige because nobody's the
points don't really matter so cranking
it up doesn't matter just give yourself
have you wait don't give yourself any
painful modifiers take
multiplier down low because you don't
care about points you might finish with
a thousand points but if you finish it
fast knock it out oh the good way to do
that so dead orbit did pull out the
victory we know it's coming right back
though this is Mike this is kind of one
thing again a lot about with no changes
I started it I literally started it just
because I wanted to get a little bit of
a jump on before I had to like jump on
the play the next like more but um yeah
man I I I liked I just want to get a
start on those packages and stuff like
that but I like that what is it is it
cool right now right now I like that
system it you know it makes you careful
it makes you cautious like you don't
want to lose that right now you want to
get the most grand those packages you
know and then I got to get the full dead
orbit set I'm still working on that so I
can get extra now yeah so I mean those
were I did my 20 minute twenty minute
rant about facts and rallies I mean so
much to do so you know yeah I was like
yeah you were out when I popped that
thing I was probably while you were in
the middle of e3 but obviously for me
okay couple things one it I hadn't done
that over before I was new monarchy but
the big drive for everybody was gonna be
that catalyst grabbed only most people
wanted it so dead orbit had pretty solid
stats last week apparently my Amazon
package was delivered thanks hmm my main
issues I did grind 250 and damn it took
a while no plate doing your dailies will
help running with a group will make
things a little quicker but the big
thing is it took me to level 37 to get
my full armor set damn yeah now that's
the problem let's make this worse I got
my full 50 I want to go future war cult
because I want that SunShot catalyst
great start that armor grind all over
again
and if it what if I'm unlucky and I just
flat-out don't know what's missing on
that extra renown you get that's missing
out on the whole bonus to it so my my
couple main issues were for one give me
a little more reason to grind with the
renowned and say if you are successful
have it away to where you can stack it a
couple more times hey I have a five
stack I pull it you get a little buff on
your character be like sweet you can get
an extra noun or you get a little extra
more next time and have that add a
couple more to give you more reason to
stay in it without dying without just
running around zones to the activities
that you do desperately need balanced
those a little bad like a crucible match
you sit there and you wait for 3 minutes
then you go into matchmaking then it
could take like a five or ten minute
match put into and if you lose you get
like two tokens yeah you know so
disproportionately unfair yeah guys so I
mean see most strikes or whatever it is
it's kind of going they just need to be
evened out so yes whether it's a raid or
a strike or a crucible match or a loss
sector give me a reason to play more
things I get it but public events and
loss sectors I know we all played them
mmm just give us more reasons to do
other stuff so if we are doing the grind
and I'm like hey you want to go do a
nightfall or something it's not like I'm
wasting my faction around the grind time
by doing other things that's a good
point yeah it should be across the board
and you should be rewarded accordingly I
completely agree with it and then my
final third thing is find a way they
they had two things they wanted to do
they wanted to make your decision matter
so it isn't a count wide thing okay
that's fine but if you want me to
actually be say like I want to be loyal
to dead orbit I have my you know my
Guardians beliefs are with them and I
feel like whatever if you want to give
it a little more weight don't make me
completely bail on my level 50 faction I
just did different catalysts put all
that list in there at like you know when
you get 50 ranks with your faction can
hear token that you can only buy one
then if I get level a hundred and I stay
with it so I've already spent the time
to grind
she'd get the armor set I put in a
buttload of time sorry almost cursed and
like give me a way to make my decision
something that I actually want to stick
with otherwise we're all just gonna
switch up for the catalyst and it
doesn't really mean squat so I mean yeah
one per account is fine but and the
other piece is to like say you have no
time in this last faction rally yep
whatever you started with now you have
to pledge to it again if you didn't get
there and if there's only three weeks of
it you literally have to get 50 in all
of them otherwise you can't do it but
what if this next time around you have
lots more time and you could potentially
grind like to level 75 ooh and then you
could get you know one and a half
catalysts and then your last one you
could go for the long grind to get the
other two if you have a hundred and
fifty levels at a faction in three
faction Early's I think you could
deserve pretty much anything would you I
mean I'm gonna be really like I like the
initial changes but it's like I don't
like that it goes away yeah why make it
so short why make it one week yeah like
why it just to me it just makes them
useless when it's not a factional
there's no reason for me to go to a day
on there's no reason they don't actually
me and Oh me alright looks like they got
a stay almost there getting better but
yeah they're not very I agree with all
the things you said you know in
reference to that grind as well and then
also it's like like you said you made a
great point which is like you know what
if you're just unlucky and you don't get
this one you know the thing so my thing
is like they don't have nothing in place
where you can use the tokens to just buy
the pieces yeah like Ella didn't like
you but you know whatever like if you
missed out you're unlucky on the boots
you're unlucky or whatever and I just
let us use our tokens like they still
got some things to do with it you don't
say I like the initial changes in the
right direction but yeah I totally agree
with you I would definitely like you
know at least the option to buy those
things I don't like that they go away
cuz again ideally what if you just can't
play that way like you're on summer
vacation what if you're up there yeah
you just done yeah and you miss out on a
whole one that's like old might not be
for everybody
Oh
that's flying games where things aren't
meant for everybody usually those things
are like harder to get to and grind to
but there's a vegetable like if you put
in the time you can if you time gate
crap mm-hmm don't do that so no on that
one as well leave it out there leave it
out make it a season 3 thing mm-hmm
hey I'm come in you can get and that was
my thing it's like you know like a
couple different guns all of them suck
so it doesn't really need if you like
how it looks it's one thing catalysts
are the one thing that our exotic weapon
so everybody's gonna have exotics the
same and they are game changing those to
eventually everyone with some more now X
150 levels in a faction that's fine
that's gonna take a buttload of work but
always have it active if you always have
it going on then it just gives
everything a bit more weight it makes
every public event mean more examine
what you could like turn it on turn it
off if you're like I just want to grind
my flashpoint real quick I don't want to
worry about renowned cool turned on turn
off whatever but like just have a way
it's like if I'm dead orbit it's for all
three four months of the faction rally
and I'm just there and it's always going
it's always going on have a weekly
Tahlia on your you know public events be
like hey and then at the end of a full
season do something major yeah like
badass like if you were dead orbit in
your faction one give me an ornament
that attaches to my back like trials of
Osiris wings back in back and you're
like okay we won season three sui has
three on my back I don't care
something cool like that and just like
you got three months have one artist
just burn out cool rewards for the three
done yeah completely
yeah faction rallies yeah steps in the
right direction as innocent baby steps
has probably been the consistent word in
all of our podcast me past like continue
continue so we got next
next armor woo I got some changes coming
yeah I do have to say we got a lot of
talk here so sorry for the quick
scanning if that looks terrible in the
stream sorry but that being said
so we know exotic armor changes were
coming they weren't done with them this
is wave so we can go through and
basically look at them as we want we'll
start with the hunter and just kind of
go through each by each I'm gonna pull
up the normal and so we know what's
going on so originally lucky raspberry
increases the chaining capabilities of
arc bolt grenade and has a chance to
recharge it each time it deals damage
what it used to do right now increased
chance to fully recharge your arc bolt
grenade on art grenade hits guarantees a
recharge on getting a full chain that
hits four targets oh so now picture that
in PDE ooh or in you know a clump of
iron banner PvP this will be harder but
in PvE
that's a lot of grenades that's a lot
yeah so and I think you said this right
because I did a quick glance yesterday
and of course I was look at this one I'm
like taking like an in-between break at
work so don't get an in-depth thought on
it you said these were subtle and they
are subtle but with sometimes more power
than you expect
so some of them may be a little better
than I give them credit for
they're still just not blowing the doors
off of it but I think my issue something
else will cover that a little bit
guarantees are recharged so what and the
basically they have their thoughts after
each one well just about everybody could
appreciate the theoretical infinite
grenades of Lucky raspberry it's purely
random nature made many people shy away
from it with this change your input will
now affect the outcome so playing your
throws accordingly if you get a group of
thrall and you're like hey I'm just
gonna melt them real quick throw it you
got it back like that's just giving you
more power good thing I've never argued
with that you know don't lend a bog with
that I'm cool ditching like I'm good
alright stop ease so previously
increased sprit speed and slide distance
and it improved double jump only now it
the increased benefits when using strafe
jump and triple jump so basically it's
across the board sprint speed slight
distance for all jumps just a universal
that see this is one of those when I'm
like why is that not the way it is the
whole from the get-go why is that not
the way it is out it's an exotic for
your class it's the only one you get to
use it only works with this type of jump
that to me feels like an oversight it
so I mean but again having a faster
sprint suite and slide distance for a
full exotic still feels kind of minor to
me I got you I got yes so some are cool
like lucky raspberry and fitted grenades
I could see we're like sub racers like
has it's cool where you can have like
five grenades of them five seconds some
of those either moments where they get
their perk they're not going to be like
I'm walking around as they knows the
entire track okay I mean you can't you
can't do that you can break the game or
some are gonna get it stop ease I'm like
I slide farther and run faster I'm like
okay oh yeah we're good I'm like I'm
never gonna use that in PvE ever right
in PvP I mean granted if you're going as
you know a pole dancer with but with if
you're running with a sword with quick
thing stuff like that I could see where
that maybe synergy could help but it
still feels binder to me so some are
better than others angry young I'm Cara
spine so what did it do before increase
trip by grenade duration and marked
enemies and you're going whoa this is
one of those definitely yeah so remove
marking functionality because it's like
who cares I mean if you're gonna hit
somebody with a grenade either it should
just kill them but that's just me
improved triple and grenade blast radius
and throw speed so you can probably get
it out a little quicker and make it so
they're harder to destroy yeah I mean I
mean honestly what I think it could do
is like I don't know you'd have to hide
it a little bit but personally I think
if it like it'd be cool like if you
destroyed it
maybe you destroy like the attaching to
the wall mechanism then it maybe bounces
around on the ground like a jumping bean
for a few seconds and then explodes like
that kind of you know make it a little
like do I want to shoot it off the wall
do I just don't want to run around that
corner for a little bit like just things
that make you think bigger blast radius
quick throw speed again it's still the
tripmine grenade that won't kill you in
one hit you could run through and then
wait and hide get your health back in
yeah so it still feels less solar
ability hits now grant some trip might
energy that's fine but if that's your
trip mind grenade energy you get some
energy back while doing it and as a
hunter you might get a punch in but
still feels meager overall now I mean
tell me if I'm speaking out of place
here if you're like hey hold on screw
you I got better I mean right now I hear
as a hunt you know you're the hunter man
for a month or so I mean I I hear what
you're coming from like some it's like
it's subtle some stuff okay but nothing
like oh my god I can't believe they did
this with that you know that I can
that's the vibe I'm getting
yep so hunters may I mean maybe I'll
have some fun with the like you're as
various we'll see Titans but again lucky
raspberry if you're going arc bulb are
you gonna use lucky raspberry over other
stuff mainly what's your big one for arc
that I'm thinking about - the chest
piece radiant radiant flux yes why would
you ever not use that I don't know
Titans a CD zero feedback fence these
are sexy and exotic yeah I did with that
ornament I'm definitely digging at the
new ornament t ohen so previously melee
kills build up explosive energy within
the feedback fence being struck by melee
attack unleashes this energy in a
devastating explosion okay so you gotta
be melee range one two you gotta get
kills with your melees which in PvE is
frickin impossible yeah I still hate how
it's a three punch kill it's just I
don't feel like I'm up there if I'm
close enough to punch you I'm a damn
guardian make my fists hit harder yeah
all right so it's just like I mean
whether it's like the force push of a
warlock a Titans just like I'm sorry I
got my haymaker or your hunter with your
knife all three of those should be two
at the max oh that's my period anyway so
now it grants fury conductor stacks on
melee hits instead of kills so if you're
wailing on a knight you can actually get
a boost to it the ER conductor now
grants stacking melee damage resistance
so melee damage resistance is good
because you're gonna be out there taking
shots as it is so basically it says
these changes are mostly am for making
fury conductors better in PvE
while the feedback fence could protect
from hordes of
throw keep punching and you know it
works if you walk up to a high of night
you're like well this is useless I mean
that well so is like again this is one
of those things in testing like okay it
works against URLs
okay now I'm against they needed me with
more health and it's useless if you have
us where your exotic is useless you got
to fix it so this is a little better
okay so they basically they make so in
crucible shooting the important this is
also it makes the exotic better than
curse well but the solution of just
shooting opponent still works no kidding
see that's just basically is like yeah
okay this sucks in PvE yeah yep yeah so
it's kind of a really subtle
acknowledgement of that doom paint
cauldrons previously shield bash melee
kills recharge shield throw melee
ability kills recharge set no shield
super okay seemed all right now void
melee kills grant more super energy okay
that's a liability kills void melee
kills that's the same thing that didn't
change the shield's throw hits will now
extend the duration of your super cool
Titans have a lot of exotics that help
with punching things to differentiate
this so yeah basically if you shield
throw with this one if you're going
Titan you're going Captain America
shield throws make it last little longer
which you know in turn bounces something
else out like radiant flux you have the
supers last longer with an exotic I
think most exotics need or most
subclasses needed exotics that extends
the length of it because that's your one
time you get to use it every three or
four minutes make that thing a little
more worthwhile and that's what your
focus is that's your bit uh doom archers
next one oh no I'm just saying that
means what does it reduce to town
activate the linear act actuators while
you were screening to one point five
seconds down from five interesting
increase the damage of Chain Lightning
effect so let me read what it did
increase sprint speed okay that's still
the same right sprinting builds up a
static charge
that's from five seconds down to one
point five which is huge
after melee attacking an enemy that
charge will
damage to nearby enemies though
basically it's 70% stronger in PvP 440
percent stronger in PvE that's a buff
right there that's a large number well
that's not 4.4 percent increase little
baby or point zero four percent I'm glad
to see large numbers on some of this
stuff occasionally yeah that's just a
step in the right direction well the
Lightning effect of do Norris was novel
the time needed start up was fairly low
so now it's just faster sprint speed get
it up quick run in punch basically if
you start sprinting towards a few an
enemy you'll probably have it ready
punch have a little fun see my only
issue with that is in PvE there's many
times unless you are faced with
something like a bunch of thralls you
don't really want to get that close to a
lot of things yeah so like the sprint
speeds cool like crank the sprint speed
up and have them melee be a bonus so you
literally pull like a Quicksilver like a
really fast run by BAM like so yes I
mean if you're gonna go punch a big in
to me and there's some enemies around
them have it be a run by Quicksilver
moment and then you know it only lasts
for say like 10 seconds you get a crazy
boost and then you're done but it's like
in PvE like I don't want to get close to
any big over there just it's like you
don't want to you don't want to play
with that style you don't want to that
style of play with just to suit that
exotic so I definitely want you coming
from with that yeah so I mean that's
just one of those like same thing with
melting point in PvE it's like it has
its perks but man it's hard to get in
there to risk it for it exactly are you
gonna really take you know that over
another exotic that's actually more you
know effective yeah so it's like if if
I'm just looking at some of these and
I'm like I still want some of you I want
the others then you didn't do enough
that's just my own opinion Oh more
subtle some are gonna get better but
overall if it until it's a hard decision
for multiple things for a certain build
I don't think you've done enough so
meaning of crown of tempest to this
warlock talk man alright I'll give you
the generals and you can take them so
courteously conduction times our ability
kills increase the recharge rate of your
arc abilities
that's honestly just a good one for your
stormcaller subclass mm-hmm now now what
does it do it
so Lauda is collapsing the total number
of the stack of the conduction times two
three with the same total effect so I
believe it used to go up to like seven
and it says so each stack of conduction
tines lowers the upkeep cost of storm
trends so basically you use your
abilities you know you say you hit Cup
group enemies or Denae Dorris melee
someone kentukcy sometimes would
activate and at that point super um the
ability to generate you know to get to
your super we're starting to increase
right so that part is okay in a sense
that they're making it down to three so
before you have to get seven and really
see a tangible effect or whatever that
high point number was yeah buddy like
okay now my soup was rising but the
problem was you know you once you use
your abilities you know it's gonna be a
while before you get them again so
you're not gonna be building that thing
up fast so I and this was actually one
of my first exact I used to use
consistently so that is saying that
Nazareth's in and this exotic were quite
similar which is true so we pushed
harder on this exotic for storm callers
we want to invest heavily in ability use
warlocks also don't have many exotics
that modify the supers and not receive
the full benefit of conduction times
during storm trance was a little
disheartening so we added a better
benefit from the supers duration to
alleviate that so I'm just curious about
this whole super duration thing because
the vibe I'm getting is that you know
yeah you're gonna be able to get to when
you get conduction times activated
you're gonna be able to build up your
super faster and I'm saying but then
they're mentioning that whole while
you're in your super and I'm saying like
I don't know lowering the upkeep costs
so that that's interests is that mean
like basically if you are killing things
that like it's like recharging as you
use it so it's actually gonna last
I'm very curious about this verbage cuz
there's this me like you said does it
does it mean when you're in your super
it makes you makes it last longer does
it mean that when your super is over now
you kind of almost like the old almost
that excited then with the black helmet
oh man I forget to get rid of it oh crap
I know you know what I've talked about
where as a warlock
was a city Obsidian modernist of the
city in mind yep yeah that's some would
like build your super backup or your
Nova bomb as you use your ass as you use
so is it only one of those things so if
I'm you know killing stuff with my super
Kentuckians I was going off you know
when it's done I'm kind of like a you
know one-fourth already towards the new
super you know say like I'm very curious
about that so that's what I got to put
through the paces before I can say this
is a really a jump I will say this the
fact that you it doesn't take as long to
stack to the maximum ability to get
sounds good off paper so I gotta say
this is what I actually just one of my
favorite looking exotics to be honest
look cool I don't think I have it
honestly what yeah it's like I've on PC
I've literally got Titan and warlock and
I'm missing this one so flat-out don't
have it I thought I had most of them so
yeah we'll see if that one gets enough
that again takes me back to just the
idea that still the abilities take a
long time to come back yeah it's way
still a cool no no I mean so it takes
ability kills our ability ability kills
right no more even there any ability
kills you up to get to build up super um
build up your times increase rate but
how mean how do you get a big how long
does it last
it generally lasted for about maybe it's
a decent my maybe about five to six
seconds or somewhere that about a
seven-second some today oh do you have
to throw a storm grenade to get all your
kills together to give big stack because
how work right you punch one person and
run across it just fade away yeah after
a while it fades away then you go back
to normal super regeneration time yeah
slow stacking is where I've see it
difficult because our abilities aren't
that often right but what would happen
is the more kill let's say for example I
do a storm grenade at a bunch of thralls
the more thralls I killed it would max
the stack up faster so we've got the max
that the recharge rate goes fast
so but but what they're doing now is
saying okay you don't have to get to
level six or seven in a stack that's now
only two three
so they letting you get to the
max version of the stack and that Mac
version it was quicker and that Mac
version the stack then definitely
regenerates you faster so I understand
that it's a subtle change it's not like
oh my god it's so great oh no said the
key is that second part of this I want
to know how that works you know I'm
saying like does that give me my super
back does that allow me to build it keep
it longer yeah well if you're melting
infinite throws running at you can you
use your super for like 20 seconds
longer just to keep melting if you're
killing guys yeah if it does that
now we're talking because in my opinion
as a storm calling I'm low key so I'm
calling don't do what it used to do man
like storm color like you do the
nightfall you doing stuff it's
struggling with yellow bars well I'm
seeing the pole dancer run around
killing boys with no products storm so
don't race ain't what it used to be
I'm telling out right now like boy walk
is the superior class for almost
everything you know saying and don't
don't late I'm getting better with but
there's only one class that's actually
good it's that bottom one
but um yeah I mean I'm curious I'm sure
that's what I got on crown of
temperature this was my first exotic and
I look like I just call it the night
king amazing show can't wait for next
year you know Karn Stein armlets so that
wears caress mainly it currently or at
least previously melee attacks grant
increased resilience and mobility of
young stacks don't matter in my book but
that's old and problem and they
highlight injured enemies which is
always weird to me mm-hm
melee kills greatly restore health
that's what it used to do so freak now
removed melee hit effects resilience
mobility target highlighting out melee
kills now instantly heal you then us
healing for eight seconds so if you get
that melee kill you get a boost to
health and then continual regeneration
for eight more seconds which is a long
time actually so you're up in a mix like
you might be able to survive a more
painful PvE situation with this thing on
you know this is a good deal I think
this one is because it was actually
first it was
this is a weird exotic because they
actually buffed it before then a nerfed
it and I'd have rebuffing it again this
constant has went to weird changes um
yeah constantly healing like if you
healing
it's almost acting like the d1 Ram cuz I
remember no matter Ram used to get like
a didn't Ram give you healing went offer
off a melee kill one of them gave hold
on I'm bringing a mild dim yeah bring up
the dim I've got the RAM he'll increased
increased armor all voidwalker melees
trigger life steel on hit yeah life and
life still was that the energy back so
this is basically doing that you're say
like you get a man to kill you Italy
here but Dan it's even better it says it
grants continuous healing by eight
seconds so you just like running around
tank always yeah I still just getting
healing over shield I mean that's gonna
last a while now if you want this to be
a really good exotic mmm give me that
melee hit oh yeah it be barely people I
don't yeah you'd be staying away from
your warlocks but still it could be cool
so again somewhat subtle some could be
better than others just gonna have to
see a few of these in action mmm-hmm
finally the good old Starfire provides
an additional fusion grenade charge a
fusion grenade kills grant rift energy
kinda straightforward so empowering rift
weapon damage now grants fusion energy
20% I see what loan infection boots
we're like giving a bonus to players who
decide to go on the offensive
rather than playing it safe with healing
rift yeah I like that I actually like
empowering so empowering
rift weapon damage so if you're in
empower grift and you do damage
now grants fusion grenade energy so if I
sit there kind of like I mean seven
seconds like twenty percent is it hit
damage like how quick is that thing
gonna recharge because if you'd like
drop a rift and you get like four or
five shots as your grenade full it's
look like the vibe I'm getting
reminds me of gone blade top tree which
is when you're in the air and you get
kills your regeneration of grenades and
whatever would go up like very quickly
so the vibe I'm getting is yet like they
are trying first in one get you to use
empowering riff that's the new thing was
they know warlocks don't use a power
that's cutable
don't use it like it's not that
effective uh so now you don't lunar
faction right which now extends this
range oh my god the shotguns I saw when
you told me that I still have to see
yeah please do me a favor send me that
actually remind me yeah okay I have to
look for it but it's just it's stupid
like crazy on callous is the big one
you're on the front plate to him they're
all in the empowering rift and a shotgun
just melts him I'm pretty sure acts
almost like a one or two phase like mode
net so that's beasty I gotta see that so
um yeah I got I got to see that but um I
think like I said with that I like them
trying to do things to make you know
empowering with good start for protocol
was a beast in d1 but now that fusion
grenades are so nerfed
you can't really get to kill but it's
it's a finisher offered I will say that
I I play that style to cheese one iron
banner for ornaments for grenade kills
yeah
now I literally I threw on star for
parkour and I was just literally
shooting people like 1 or 2 times and
just throwing a grenade I didn't care if
they killed me you know be thrown open
it on a back and I was getting agreement
will see it means it Denny says if the
the with the rift damage now grants
fusion grenade 20% so if you do damage
like if I go I mean sweet business you'd
be having grenades for days but just
even anything if it's damage hits like
scout rifles like 20% 20% 20% like if
it's not that's sounds fast that's
that's why I'm wondering how quick is if
what's like the cooldown between because
that rift only last like 10 seconds so
you brought make it worthwhile so is
that quick it's kind of gotta be yeah we
got to see we got a seashell
the overpressure in a chat he said he
doubts that it's gonna stay there for
very long
yeah I'm saying what yeah he also says
that the Starfire protocol really makes
two or lock for team very effective I
agree I'm gonna because it's like if you
guys if you got more likes letting
Starfire and they're just it again it's
not saying kills it's just saying weapon
damage
so you're just shooting people and
you're going again getting the love
these buffs for the armor is loving on
the warlocks and I have a warlock - but
I'm just saying like the way we're
talking about these this class versus
the other two like our discussions here
sound more you know you be hopeful the
other two are kind of like but let's be
real like I feel that I'm pretty sure
deej is in here right now so I'm gonna
build it because I feel for my super
standpoint
warlocks just don't they need to love
like I just I dove the lead us to see
that the Slover okay you know I'm saying
you know dawn blade to get that super
office still it's not a guarantee kind
of thing like trying to run away from
pole dancer Golden Gun like those are
all still in saying like hey the long
range into the kills kind of brutal
effect and nice talkers of hunter is
like I don't want get none from hunters
like y'all right now or the matter like
it snowed out and then it tightens come
on I can tell you need somebody hit me
with a strike it I was like a good
distance away in the air oh my god I was
like are you serious now see it
vertically cleared either you may as
well not even try you better and then
I'm not even forgetting about the speed
of the strike at Titan now and yeah you
can't runner you're a karate you're not
gonna cut you're not getting away so
that's my thing with me well I got slow
week Palpatine tickle fingers that ain't
killing nobody no more you don't say
like it's this day night they're super
the only one that I will say okay
is really good feel free to chat st.
Opie the only one I know I feel from a
warlock perspective is the void lock you
know saying you eat the panini get
health back I'm saying I actually run
Slover bill too cuz Slover kind of has
that mini tracking and then it splits
into three or four and sometimes you
could really get some multi tails off or
complain and it got bleak so I can't
complain about voice announcing voice
kind of the best class overall for like
PvE content as well yes oh that's just
me I think they need to do something
Wallace but I really would hope by
forsaken right now cuz shout out the
reddit man cuz they put out a thing
about if storm trans does not get
something it is literally the weakest
super in PVE pvp yeah can't compete no
more they over nerfed it yeah right uh
but I mean yeah that's the stuff on the
armor my big thing but again I mean
doing for forsaken or after I just want
the armor stats and perks and I still
have not seen very much of anything on
that and that's my big worry exotics
slowly getting better I mean some of
these as we're saying like some are
still mediocre some are kind of
potentially through like you know could
be fun but I was like with whatever arm
right I have four other slots to fill
and if I don't care about those that
still kind of sucks for the grind so
I've been saying it for a while and it's
old she was like just destined it's like
it's been twelve hundred days since the
vault has been increased it's like it's
been way too long for d2 the armor
having any effect to your character
outside of like minor mobility minor
resilience minor recovery like once
that's the matter I want decisions to
absolutely matter absolutely
and like I said the hope is with you
know I'm with you man I don't get me
wrong like I just think that right now
you know saying we know it I get that
and I said but I mean as far as before
forsaking what for would forsaken
there's a strong chance there's a strong
chance we got to see what they're gonna
do with the armor and stuff like that
you know so so sorry I'm trying to pull
up an image just to be able to show you
here you know worse so I'm gonna pull
this over here on the screen real quick
so just an idea I know this looks insane
mm-hmm
now this is from a game called path of
Exile okay now this is obviously way
over the top this is a skill tree for
path of Exile oh my god Potts it's come
on no I'm saying yes very so these there
are two extremes you have destiny that
literally is a fork in the road and
that's like way too simplified you have
this which is way way way way way over
the top
now the here's a like you have your main
because I look it's free so buddy you
start here and like so if you go caster
like mage I'm going here but you can
pick all these but you can literally go
like one two and like work your way
through and completely work for a
different customization even though I'm
a caster hmm honestly like even if
destiny was just like a little tiny
function like this little chunk right
here like give yourself a couple options
like I miss d1 skill trees ba that's the
stuff that I want back to it's like
there we need more I just need a little
more P I just like I saw that thing and
I just have out because he showed it to
me I was like oh my god and then I
jumped in the game and I'm like alright
I'm gonna kind of start here but I feel
like I'm kind of clueless but yeah give
me a little more of that no but you know
I agree I literally think that was part
of D that was one of the best parts of
d1 that my new show of tweaking every
little ability bubble you know I'm
saying try to figure out different Billy
just made you feel like you had
different playstyles and with this whole
everything just you know block a block B
smorgasbord is simple you know so it
would be you know it it just it's just
to casualized that was that that was a
design decision that we always complain
about
I think I'll shout out to do goes in
chat go ham he said he bought us if they
use a more customizable talent tree the
teams would be 200 P versus solo Q
that's why they are more simplistic okay
you say that one fix the solo Q problem
yes
overwatch since it came out litter
if it's a one two and a three in there
you're against a 1 a 2 and a 3
mmm why is that so hard if you had it
right in the beginning your player base
may not have run away from you but
that's what the other piece is now
anybody who actually you're gonna have
your casuals in any game you're gonna
have somebody and destiny that's running
hey I'm running warlock and I don't even
have the right jump on I may not have a
green haircut
there's gonna be casual coolest people
no matter what you do the people who
take two seconds are gonna be like hey
what's a good skill tree run to go right
now you have to go crazy in depth but
it's like okay what is my skill tree
right now in my build what is my skill
tree for you know and it's like okay and
like literally what I would do a
nightfall guide video I'd be like okay
I'm sticking with this bubble I'm going
with this one for fire for health regen
a couple things and you're good at like
right you take away the customization
options everybody's playing the same and
then you literally just have a class
shooter you don't have an organ you
don't have a there's a good you don't
have a party and you have a class
shooter that's a good point
I said you say and to me the most
egregious thing and she'll go for we
don't bring this up is good good talking
point is that the most egregious thing
is that they had this system t1 so you
can't always against games and this is
any video used to get this mad with
sports games like I'm always against a
franchise regressing features like you
are not allowed to regress a feature
that you yourself implemented in the
initial game you're saying like you
can't I'm still man this is completely
off topic but my madam plays any few of
you at all one of you or two of you in a
chat if you play Matt like there we
should be a thing called defensive
assignment where you can move Nate you
can customize the defender to guard a
specific offensive player all around the
field just think that Deion Sanders
Cowboys back in his head right now since
like for whatever Madden has taken our
future way and you can't do it anymore
so I don't know what the design choice
maybe was an AI think maybe he screwed
things up with their AI simulation but
the point of the whole point of this
whole matter is it was a feature that
was in there that was beloved and now
they just take it taken away and that's
all I'm saying with the skill tree and
that's why I agree with you is that with
the skill tree stuff
I definitely feel you know saying like
we need to go back to D 1 where imagine
at least if we can pick between the
different abilities from top you know
I'm saying like how it used to be that's
always saying Ellen so if you pick you
know say if I pick void okay you have
your grenade choices it'd be nice just a
little variation on those two you say I
did pick a void wall grenade it's
horizontal or vertical even something
that simple gives you an option of how
you're gonna like do you want a wall for
somebody to cross or do you want to
light up an entire strip so there's no
way in hell we're running through it
right do you go on a storm grenade do
you want a condensed storm to put on a
heavy enemy or do you want to a larger
vast storm that's light or damage on a
bigger like area just like tagging
people but maybe kill enthralls yes even
those little choices and then give me a
few more to it let me have not just like
all of four or these four and that's it
and that that's like literally your only
choice just give me a few more options
okay so here's the so you're saying
better players would used it to Massacre
people okay yeah good like that see the
problem shout out the idea I love the
other like he's always in a chance he
goes super hard for I hope he'd love
them so we're not trying to attack you
know these are good good perspective
like absolutely and I hear what you're
going and what you're saying is what
Bungie did at the start of d2 they
didn't want to casual eyes that they
want to catalyze they wanted to make it
more accessible the problem is as we've
discussed in flashpoints before when you
casual eyes something you make it easy
then what happens is the hardcore get
bored then the the cashews once they
play and they got everything they want
to do out of the game they're gonna lead
it's that my new sure like that the
customization is too minutia like weapon
rolls and random weapon placement that's
what gets people to keep coming back cuz
like you I found this new build you know
let's try it out oh I got I got this
drop with said roll you know said Joe
this makes this one obese like that's
that evolute let never lasting gameplay
loop that maybe one what it was when you
take that away it simplifies the game
you get everything out of
but she went Freddie initially you have
fun you get everything out you want but
then you don't really come back to the
game because you don't have that my
Anusha
that's almost mmm yeah that's a balance
to make a game accessible but also have
a very high scale ceiling it's okay to
people jump in a game and be like hey I
can run around I can shoot and this is
where I think they're matchmaking need
some work or something along on the
lines of like overwatch does they need a
letter or a tier they need a gold a
silver a bronze a platinum a diamond if
they need something like that to
separate the players into a chunk like
you need to have like if I'm mediocre
and I'm not claiming to be amazing I'm
not gonna be in diamond tiers no way in
hell and crucible am I in diamond tier
though if I'm in that middle tier I'm at
least hanging in that middle realm now
if I work on it hard you know I'm
playing against people similar to me
playing against people way too high
against you doesn't make anything that
much fun playing against people you
stomp on you don't get better playing
people who are roughly around your level
say if there's a hundred and I'm like in
that gold middle tier I'm say ninety out
of a hundred but I'm sitting there
playing against the guy who might be one
in there he's still in that relative
realm he's kind of out of reach but I
can work on creeping up that's how you
get better at it
that's what listen man I used to get
stopped in truck I said it's the
lostness to tell I wouldn't even touch
trials when definitely first Pony I'm
like I used to get destroy you know my
first couple of crucible experiences
when destiny one started like I got
stomped it I was like you know what and
then I remember going to the tower I
remember seeing people with unique E and
I've never seen the trial set for the
first time now I need that I got a I got
a I did stop until I started playing
with a regular group and just trying to
get better and they were like look don't
worry you know we play Charles you know
you just do this maybe they carry me I'm
not gonna make any I got no Eagle I got
carry to my first lighthouse you know
that and I was like but you felt so good
with that doctrine of passing drop for
me kid like those are the moments those
get good moment so to speak you know
and that's why I love everything we see
with d2 right now like yeah maybe maybe
people don't like the losing street of
glory but I like the fact that there's
that vendor exclaim or when you see
somebody whether you like yo he put it
now or you know you know me like that's
what those are things to strive for you
know saying and I hate it when d2 came
out and it catalyzed it you know I'm
saying and me everyone you know I'm
saying like it just get this get all the
rate weapons and all like come on
Hawthorn was giving stuff away like it
was candy and I'm just like hey you know
say so that's my rant on that but yeah
this is good these a good talking place
no I mean absolutely and that's kind of
one of those that's like think about a
game like fortnight you okay you can run
in I mean battle royale sorry for
tonight's different but I'll for
fortnight you can run in there you can
have some fun pub G the same thing to
get to that elite level it takes skill
now sometimes like I've even like one a
pub G match I've had like two I mean
they're they're few and far between but
that makes that link desire to try and
get better that desire to play hey I'm
gonna play a little safer and there's
some orangy involved that you understand
that but it's the higher this get like
the people who can turn around and like
ride a rocket the person who did that
the first time in fortnight that is
insane but that's the level that's you
wanna you can't put the cap so high that
your elite elite players can't feel
elite otherwise what's the point was on
you don't have anything to shoot for you
don't have any to strive for you don't
have anybody to watch you don't have
anything to be like hey this is a cool
thing to do cool I mean drag sniping and
destiny like that used to be the way it
the elites like made it look so easy and
you're just like how the hell you
pulling that off what it's like you want
to try and figure it out now sometimes
it's like hey I may not figure it out
you're better than me cool and I
understand that's why I'm not gonna be
in diamonds here but yeah I think
playing around your level having some
distinction between separating your
levels things like that would just be a
nice piece to so oh yeah always good
Chuck definitely do go getting our minds
working this one like I mean there's
that's was like there's things but I was
like I kind of I hope they're not gonna
go screw the pooch on d3 but if they are
working on it like listen to some of
these things give me some more options
because a
sometimes I feel like d2 is still so
committed into what it had to do to be a
release in itself I can't make system
depth level changes like stats and armor
and stuff and I just have to aside to
that but hey uh anyway so the old gods
there's some stuff on servers that are
old if you have old halo stuff go get it
otherwise it's going away simple cool
simple next yeah fighting lion that iron
banner ornament same thing if you have
the fighting iron iron banner ornament
and you have it on one leave it there
mmm-hmm otherwise it's probably gonna go
yeah and it's gonna be a while till you
get it back so if you have it equipped
on the weapon don't get rid of it you'll
hold on to it for the rest of you guys
it's just they're gonna work on fixing
there's some glitch and that's about it
yeah other than that guys you got a few
videos there's good old Kade from d1 yo
that K video I do watch has kind of good
did you see it yeah no that one's pretty
crazy a couple videos nightfall scores
are crazy out of the top if that's
Slayer age not surprising he's in there
beast yeah so he even said like your
eyes here in PvE so that basically wraps
this one up there's one little article
came across and wanted to cover it quick
with you guys it's just a little bit
about forsaken and we're just gonna hit
these kind of get our thoughts on each
point so it's just twelve points about
forsaken eight is that good we kind of
covered that wait yeah hundred percent
dead and not coming back and for their
discussion reveals that yes totally bad
so I mean they made the wait so we'll
see how it turns out now number two is
kind of cool now when they did the
reveal there's like hey there's eight
barons you need to go through one could
be a sniper battle ones this big melee
guy okay they have different feels if
you actually have the choice in the
direction because it says the campaign
has a nonlinear mission structure okay
so you've done this you've gone through
the campaign we got to this point all
right so now there's eight trees you can
go out and you see your pick on which
one you do it's like a little Mega Man
station I'm like that actually could be
kind of cool what else how difficult
some may be heavy some may be stronger
so you might have a limit in which order
you go on but if you think you got the
sniper wits and they're a harder one to
kill but you can Duke it out
maybe you get a little higher boosting
year who knows if it's not linear just
like do these five in a row I'm okay
with that
seriously younger year two is all about
deep long-term reasons to play so hello
huh
that's what we want I mean we want the
hobby I they keep saying the hobby I
mean and that's a lot of what d1 was it
was a hobby to get on to do this stuff
grinding for gambit is gonna be a whole
bunch of people's time and they've also
said the expansion pass your thoughts on
it or not are like no one's gonna force
you to buy the expansion past right the
season that stuff's always gonna come
out now your new content no one's gonna
say yes you have to go buy it but if you
want to wait just enjoy the first part
of the game now see how it is that's
fine
forty bucks I'm gonna get more than that
and that's my personal preference if you
don't want to fine but the fact that I
think what they're gonna add is less
cinematic story because I mean no
offense like curse of Osiris and war
mind like they kind of give me the hurt
in the fields it just it kinda sucks
and I mean it's unreal eyes potential
with little drastic yet you have Osiris
which is one of the biggest talked about
people in all of v1 and then the war
mind which I was all around in like this
moon everywhere you finally get to see
both of them for about five sites and
how are they not a new thing how are
they not more involved playing so if
they can't get that stuff right or they
gotta put myelin on d3 to make it feel
right cool if for now your your d2
season pass is gonna run like this and
honestly here's another piece to think
about as well you have games they're
pumping out content
some people like hey it's not that much
what does Call of Duty give you a few
maps maybe one zombie map I mean you
don't get a lot in your season passes
generally you're gonna have PDE content
you're gonna have a strike or two you're
gonna have new weapons you're gonna have
new things like that not many other
games can push that much out that
quickly in the first place anyway then
the ones that do you pay a monthly fee
to do it yeah that is that is true so
you have something like World of
Warcraft that's twelve bucks a month
cool they give you big huge patches
because they get one
50 bucks out of you a month a year
you're paying a chunk but when you do
that and you actually have the content
to do it that's fine they're trying to
get 30 bucks at 35 bucks out of us for a
full year of content right give us more
things to do more activities more Maps
more guns more everything complain it
about price I'm sorry when it comes to
the game press re I'm ranting here no go
for it go for it
when it comes to the game price thing
you known in Nintendo 64 games used to
be $80 and now they have fallen back
down to $60 and now people complain
about the free-to-play games the amount
of time and effort put into all these
and the amount of money spent to make a
game would blow the doors off of you or
if you were trying to run a business
making a video game as hard as hell
honestly what you couldn't finish
honestly when it comes to asking for
like 35 bucks for what is basically like
a subscription but not if this is your
hobby and you want to play a fine
no one's gonna force you into that pass
in 40 bucks for basically what is a game
now my only caveat to this before I let
you go is the fact that I really hope
they get their crap together
and somehow either bundle it or
something or if you're gonna buy
forsaken it's 60 bucks and it includes
everything from you know buying the
previous two expansions for me I'll say
it it's [ __ ]
absolute garbage that is no yes
that's because if you want in the first
second fine let me buy forsaken realize
that not everybody wants it and if you
don't want to go play the old story
content fine but do a point in d1 or in
in Forsaken it just wraps it all in
there you've had your year to try and
get your money out of that it's time for
the new one period I agree one piece
figure 2 that you require that I would
if forsaken was 60 but you didn't have
to buy the old ones I'd still be more
okay with it yeah absolutely if they if
they make for is it's aching you know 60
is a new game you know it has all the
stuff I'm cool with that
you buy the combo like the forsaken in
the annual pass it wraps up everything
you got d2 year one completely as well
like if you're gonna spend seventy are
you done with it you don't don't don't
cut them in half don't cut your bass in
half don't limit it you got
to going full annual pass bags you
stealing up a pointy I know
but yeah I was like you got other games
going free you got other stuff like I
understand they have a lot to do but you
still like make it just like any free
game I would rather buy a free to play
game on a phone for 20 bucks and just
have all this stuff in like nickel and
dimed me to death like give me the
option so not with you I mean like I
said the thing the thing right now is
that the reason why the scoring is
coming their way literally is that um
the problem is the climate has changed
and you got games like anthem you know
division to changing their model to not
armed to basically give you expansions
for free right so there's that aspect
you know I'm saying and then we have you
know to microtransaction aspect know
that up stuff and let's be honest you
know Activision has not been the
greatest we just got sold you know damn
you I got so because I got weak and I
bought it the damn iron banner emo I
like a lot II uh you know this I love
podcast so I'm a little you know oh wait
I was weak
a guy I got the moment but um you know
ultimately is one of those things where
it's just like you know they've gotta
they've gotta work on that whole
reputation with these kind of Michael
Jackson and things and being with the
climate with them with destiny that
outside expansions are not free now I do
not expect that our team marketing team
all these teams that put in all this
amount of time to sit there and be like
cuz you know what you know what I'm
saying people that are like oh it's
supposed to be free because they messed
up no you know saying oh it's not free
pretty sure that's not right yeah like
I'm seeing that and that to me that's
nonsense like with someone's like yo you
know that's like you you know buying a
car getting all this use out of it right
yeah and then oh you know well it's not
good as last year's model okay good but
you got enjoyment out of you you played
it you played if you were so disgusted
you should have took it back initially
right and trade
be done you don't come back so all this
now that you seeing that the the latest
installment of the game quote-unquote
new new car model right is looking
everything great like you're supposed to
get some type of refund or rebate but
because the last year nah man you paid
that money that is it is what it is you
never say you can't go back now and
that's the only thing I completely
disagree with you know I mean so they
still got ways to go with certain things
I hope they handle the forsaking owning
content stuff
I hope they handle that and make it 60
cuz to make somebody spend one hundred
and eighty dollars that's crazy
yeah I'm pretty confident that's not
gonna happen I'm very confident they're
gonna do some all you know year one
edition or whatever it is right and
that's what I'm waiting on I said it
allows me it's gonna come you know I'm
saying at another time that kind of
judge say so
would you get I mean yeah that was a big
tangent but yeah I mean deserve I mean I
did it to Long Point for sure sorry but
your sleep but they said they give you
long term reasons to play if they do
more things like gambit more things like
escalation protocol more raids more
in-game stuff like that and they like
hey the story's not the big focus this
time around it's fine honestly I'm okay
with that so that's what we are that's
the what gives us the Hobby anyway so
straight up so the derivative City will
be a challenging player different
proposition or the story is built from
the experience so it sounds cool in just
the fact that it's actually tied to the
story first off the in-game world is
actually tides up story we're fightin
Calais BAM or were fighting uh Gaul and
all of a sudden your raids on this other
new ship and his name Calais this guy is
new if you didn't do an adventure what
the hell is going on yeah you don't have
that moment so hopefully the connection
will be there that's a step in a huge
proper direction and the fact that it's
actually just an in-game area like even
if you don't do the raid you can still
jump her in there look for the puzzles
do all that type of stuff you don't need
a raid for all of it which is cool it's
also an in-game alternative for non
writing players okay fine I was a little
early on what I said hahaha
it connects the actions they do they
sort of rating is hard but they want to
give more people an option to go explore
that
area runaround still solve some puzzles
then if you want to go to a raid do that
now one thing I do want to say to a
normal difficulty nightfall
has to get matchmaking normal difficulty
raid after about a month or two but
matchmaking in there give them a little
while nightfall regular night falls if
they have to stay at 2:15 my god that
needs to be normal who do I'm not makin
if you want a raid race and groups
that's fine absolutely people out there
and give people a hey this is a match
made raid dumb it down a little bit yeah
I don't care like world did that to they
had match made raids they're like ok
here's this if you don't have it all I
mean may have to be like hey you have to
have a mic test test we need to hear
your voice type thing but once you do
that go for that and they're worried
about their so afraid but I'm sorry too
many people have done L if to use
another stuff anyway you're just dealing
people out of it so stop it yeah I mean
the problem is that what does it gotta
get you just sucks it's still not where
I need to be
I think Paul Tassie said it best guided
games is really slow crappy matchmaking
pretty much yeah that's all it is it's
crappy slow matchmaking but doesn't
doesn't make anything better it just
makes everything worse mm-hmm so is this
your photo right here on the bottom of
my page for the Queen maybe or okay I
still haven't seen it's a girl important
milestone activities are getting a much
needed upgrade and story missions will
actually matter again so I heard there's
a date a heroic story missions daily
challenges that stuff all needs in there
so that's huge um just the daily heroic
story mission a chance for some powerful
gear just a reason to log in every day
yeah
alright that's huge so the day-to-day
experience all that stuff and bounties
again that's a huge question I have no
idea what they're gonna do yeah very
true to see how to handle that whole new
daily story missions bounties what if it
was like you know every 10 bounties you
do you turn something and you might get
a piece of gear as slow as the grind is
right now that would not kill anything
that back grind that would give it just
some reasonableness to it right cuz
right now once you hit 370 holy crap
it's slow like real slow
oh yeah the new subclass evolution
sounds like a big upgrade but still uses
preset skill trees which is you know but
there's more of them at least you can
think of these as supers there's nine
new supers we have the subclass paths
like that yeah
because every subclass you know you need
to pass now we're adding a third path
for for all nine so gonna have more
options in here which will be good so
kind of curious to see what that looks
like maybe a little bit more
customization but it still seems like if
you're on this super you get maybe one
or two max options it's not like here's
this one I want to have shield throws
but I want to have devourer and yeah hmm
the new supers have more nuanced depth
beyond their descriptive ability and
support skills are big focus kind of
like what you played for the Warlock it
sounds like yeah I mean just the fact
that you have like a big giant healing
super rift should be huge and I'm very
curious to see what the actual you know
downright abilities of that super do you
know yeah like I mean is the Superman
one gonna have a noticeable difference
of any feel of like melee boosts or
grenade changes or what like how much of
the trees are actually gonna change I
wonder we'll see mmm huh weapon [ __ ]
changed I think this is the biggest one
for everybody cuz my curiosity is like
yeah you can put I think I've heard a
couple things 104 weapon slots the it's
gonna take the new ones to drop into the
slots like right but it's also gonna
take like a shot a kinetic shotgun to be
usable in that slope I can't just use
Hawthorne's in my cannon ride so and I'm
sure it's like legacy code or legacy
weapons and changing them up might be
rough so we'll see if that's the case
though with as many weapons and choices
we have right now they basically need to
double it to give you a fair amount
options yes so I was like if they're
only I'd like to kinetic shotguns and
two of this and then the other yeah you
can do stuff but it's like that whole
piece of choice and I know there's gonna
be random roles but still I just see how
they're balanced the new stuff the
random roles or is just better devil
still god tear and every other hand can
you get my
get a good roll throughout if it doesn't
it still you're just using your better
devil so yeah dado had a good video on
this and he carrying stuff forward yeah
and I actually actually read them out
actually at first when I thought about
it I'm like Danis sucks they're better
devils and the old stuff is not gonna
get brought forward with the random
rolls but when I thought about it I'm
like cuz if it was all they're gonna do
is just use better that was again we're
not gonna use any any new weapons
because you know better Devils by itself
naturally it was already good you know
I'm saying kind of thing so it's kind of
gonna force us to use new weapons and
play around other stuff so I'm actually
alright with it
I'm actually coming around on that now
yeah I mean it's I know everybody like
you put in your time you put in your
work and there's so many things it's
like okay so if I get a dead orbit set
maybe that's something you can transmog
the set or at least the dead orbit you
know benefits of faction rallies and
stuff and keep it with you but the fact
that late and I mean in World of
Warcraft a new expansion will come out
and your gear dropped at a level yeah
I'd have like the ultimate gear for
level 70 but now we're going to 80 as
soon as you 72 that level 70 stuff even
though it was like elite for that level
gone yeah and you just do what you were
gonna get was better so I like just for
the fact that too many things late and
then you wouldn't have better devils you
wouldn't have your midnight coup that
type of stuff would it be part of the
previous year and you move on people are
stuck on that like I have my one
comfortable gun like yes that's what it
is it's like you gotta have some pride
it's like okay in year two this will be
the new thing and that'd be a good way
to shift the meta occasionally do you
know because like I said like again tad
I was a fantastic video out you know
some people's d1 loadout didn't move
from fate bringer black hammer
Gjallarhorn yep
you literally had everything from every
situation and when they brought our
house of wolves with a derrick light you
know you just level those stuff up again
yes still you for the same loadout that
you always you so it to me it's exciting
to see okay the new forsaken weapons are
all gonna have you know I'm saying like
random roles and stuff like that and now
you know somewhere some other archetypes
that maybe weren't as good in the
beginning of d2
become better with these extra perks
these roles on them so we're gonna see
at least one gaming you should be 48
hours man
you gotta be got him for me thank you
I got you Jeff so that's just one of
those that I think it's like yeah it's
like oh I spent all this time grinding
for it okay that's fine you've had it
for a while you've had it for months
it's time for all of the year-to-year
two's new find something new this is
content that I get over it I about so
much it's like and especially baby
wambulance salty some existing weapons
will change slots and old gear can be
infused to the light level for a high
cost I'm curious what the high cost is
maybe there's only a couple to move over
but my only problem is everyone's gonna
bring better Devil's Manan curtaincall
sins of the past midnight you're gonna
break and weapons over not 120 weapons
you're gonna bring your main 10 and
unless your other stuffs better what's
the point so it's like that's where
that's the issue the fall so hmm and
again stuff for them to think about for
d3 crucibles first key change will come
from weaponry categorization yeah it's
just gonna be like so what if better
Devils moves what if so there's things
move around like what if you what if you
can't use better doubles in graviton at
the same time yeah that's like just to
see where things shift around Tribune so
I mean if they move stuff around that at
least give some things kind of a switch
so builds will have to change yes can't
you so I mean what if you use better
Devils in any Oh at the same time listen
this is exciting stuff I love that type
of stuff you know and it basically you
go to that process of learning what
that's one fun and then like it's fun
like when you I remember in the early
start some expansion I kind of find like
a flow and I'm like oh this combination
is sick or this web people don't know
about it like it's a fun thing I enjoy
and then it also gets you to try
different things I instead of just just
get out your comfort zone get out to the
little whiny comfort zone of plant using
the same weapon and then try to figure
it out that's what I would say and that
actually looks like from d1 but they
said the void Hunter simple for the fact
that I don't know if you guys are
picking up or not so if you're playing
gambit apparently boy hunters have been
gonna be able to see through walls yes I
don't know yeah those void hunters have
been complaining for a long time there's
subclass of choices we can pvp largely
due to the underpowered and inconsistent
effect of super I will agree with that
I'm sorry a direct with the bow should
kill you doesn't matter but well now you
can see through walls happy now you
literally have a cheating as a subclass
ability haha insane what is it like I
don't know crazy x-ray vision or
something like that that we gotta see
about this all the crazy bananana sucide
interesting so July 17th is not that far
it'll be six days after my birthday so
you know its thing to look forward to it
for that but generally we've got that
coming up the fall is gonna be crazy
I mean new crucible boat by the way
that's not gambit that take different
crucible mode so that's a good thing
yeah more maps both like okay like
things to fix
just the shader system yes I want to see
the mods for the just the whole shader
system I'm sorry if you unlike a shader
be done with a quick trying to make them
a consumable it's so stupid weapons law
changes weapon randomization in-game
trans gear collections vault space
game lower bail more new bounties I love
other bounties new bounties like you
baddest yeah battering an iron banner in
trials like there's a lot of good things
in gambit as a whole new world so if you
want a whole new from 11:00 so we got a
lot of good stuff to look forward to I
don't know I mean how you feeling after
e3 is anything gonna you gonna still get
your detail on come fall or 14,000 other
games gonna take it away from you listen
I mean I'm still gonna play I mean I'm
excited that's why I remember we talked
at the very beginning at his flash point
I think that showing the K death was
necessary yeah you had like that it just
hit a shout-out to like what a baby like
it really gave you that emotional kick
it made people angry it made people
emotional like hi didn't you just
thought about the food's like how is you
know shoutout to um what you call in the
chat Alice one gaming like how's desti
gonna move forward like it's all these
questions that he was the levity he was
all these things so now we get to see
you know from a narrative standpoint you
know hot a handle at who was a new
hunter Vanguard what's going on with
that and then the vibe I'm getting
there's a lot of layers to this ocean
thing you know yeah I heard one thing 30
he might not even be the big battery of
all ya know just like older and it's not
like you're in game there's more beyond
so curious about that I want to see
where they go with that then we got the
whole awoken city right you know saying
like that's I like my characters in a
woken character you know so it's like
I've always wanted to know more about
that law or more about that and then
that raid being in that dedicated place
you know there's a lot of things they
can go there's a lot of directions they
go that can really get this thing
popping and like I said I'm very excited
besides like I said without thinking the
Kay death had to happen it happen not a
had to happen but it it had to be
revealed to get the juice if you just
show a regular trailer you
don't show any old ring you just saw oh
it's just a you'd be using a sex it's at
the reef it's trash yeah I could I can
already tell you like that's what people
are gonna say and not like oh they
partied like when the ghosts got killed
yep I saw that I was like oh yeah - well
you know we're gonna see so well thank
you guys for sticking with us yeah it's
been a couple weeks we had a lot to get
out there I know we got off on a couple
tangents I mean the armor it's stepping
in the right direction I give little
things but honestly it's like the bigger
stuff like we got a lot of questions and
summer solstice will be a a dabble
they're gonna have to talk about the
procedure aid layers see what's going on
with those because I honestly think
that's still too little too late to
matter yeah
but bound bounties is probably my bigger
question I want to know what they're
doing but other than that we got a lot
to look forward to again we'll try and
get back to a consistent basis I think
we're both home for a little bit I know
I'll be gone for a week in late July but
that'll probably be after the Solstice
so we'll probably be alright yeah
then we get to look forward to the fall
and if you're a gamer so get them to be
alive there's a lot to play and there
will be more this year as an insane
amount of stuff to play this here o
backlogs gonna be crazy
you know guys well I mean I think that's
a good place to wrap it so yeah thank
you guys for all the content the chat
always definitely appreciate all you
guys hanging out with us for nearly two
hours which is bananas but thanks look
every time oh oh oh yeah for me if you
guys see on the thumbnails Cognito got a
nice new logo redesign - let's look in
snazzy I'm working on mine as well and
work on some tweaks I'm gonna have a
couple options but yeah sticking with my
cheetah theme but we gonna crank it up
to a little better-looking and wait so
yeah I mean otherwise you guys know
where to find me
twitch.tv slash Yvonne test twitter.com
Yvonne test and on YouTube you know
follow that follow the channel subscribe
hit the alert bells likes comments you
guys know all the good stuff
those little things like that I know you
guys here am in a lot of videos but they
help our channel really help a lot more
than you know so if you drop a like if
you enjoy what you like watching and
keep coming back hit the subscribe
button guys it helps a ton so thank you
thank you it makes the things like your
III trip even possible I appreciate it
man yeah absolutely it's definitely what
you saying is it's very important like I
mean anytime you guys jump in the chat
even if it's for a second it really
means a lot you guys have to like you
actually subscribe we're trying to put
out good content for you you know
obviously we three at other things and
then um yeah actually know where to find
me at Lord kognito on Twitter and all
that good stuff lord I need Oh on Xbox
and academically she's you know
PlayStation as far as um this Sunday
Lord's Day will return no the inner
circle never would have especially
episode so I'm gonna actually I'll break
it here I tend to break guests on
flashpoint we will have the design
director from undead labs the LPD
winning sea state of decay richard foggy
in the building it's gonna be fun should
be a good one please tune in please
support you know we're gonna have we're
gonna we're not gonna soft ball we're
gonna ask tough questions to it as a
borough and also obviously we're gonna
talk about the microsoft acquisition you
know I'm saying because that now
hopefully goes from a double a
experience to a triple a experience so
please tune in Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern
the inner circle Network Sunday is the
Lord's Day Richard fogey will be in the
building so stay tuned for that
so a that'll be awesome looking forward
to it yeah that's what we'll leave you
guys enjoy your weekend
every cell is a good one whether you're
cooking like I am down here in Texas
like fry an egg on the sidewalk
or if you got something a little more
comfortable farther north enjoy it but
it's a toasty one but to all you guys
out there good afternoon good morning or
good evening around the world wherever
you're checking us out thank you guys
and have a good one I'm su please